so I will talk about you know it's kind
of like a reality check right I mean we
are talking about the big orbits
somewhere in the very big space well
let's check if we can do something for
small orbits working we can for example
classify them and everything so so I'll
be talking about G will be say
productive group or semi simple maybe
later
and these irreducible representation
well and actually I'll be working under
the assumption that there are only
finitely many
and then G orbits I'll tell you a little
bit about the list because these are
classified I'll tell you a little bit
about the list a little later but you
know now if you are in such easy
situation let me maybe talk about what
algebra I would like to do in such
situation what is the algebra is dream
wish list you know what could we do with
a orbit so so the wish list well you
know you have this so let's take s to be
the coordinate ring CoV I'm working over
K equals C so you might want of course
you have orbits or X then I have this
actually we better talk about orbit
clovers because they are somehow wells
are closed brake sets so what would an
want from this to know about this ring
so first of all as we it was our table
there several times it's very important
to know whether Co X is the condition of
the orbit culture whether it's normal
and the point is then in such situation
the coordinate rink of the orbit itself
is equal to the coordinating of the
orbit clover
then what you like maybe to do let me
maybe you would like to know
so s mode I will be my coordinate drink
of this orbit closure or X maybe you me
which bombed are obviously orbit
chlorine no no I just look at all orbits
in representations factor in the orbit
but you know it will be just concrete
examples you have list so sometimes the
boundary is not small okay so there
would be non normal orbits and what I'll
be talking about it's not insulting
about this shouldn't be like see alerts
poly or something
oh all right well so maybe if it's
normal with one additional assumption we
said the reason why we are interested in
normality right that you can deduce the
quality but the restriction map oh oh I
see
okay yeah yeah if the boundaries class
code I mentioned - yeah okay then it
implies but anyways that's the reason to
study normality the other point I want
to make then you would maybe like to
calculate the Hilbert series of this s
what I which is summation it's a power
series
you just want to calculate this will be
graded rings this all those orbits will
be conical varieties so so you you know
this is a Hilbert serious and it's
always will be of the form and its
dimensional V I guess
that's what I'm getting at that's right
you would like to know also that's right
so that's a wishlist and then I'll tell
you what is true in those cases and
what's not true and in what cases we
cannot decide which you would like to
know whether they have rational
singularities but maybe let me talk
first of all about kind McAuley property
in particular this is related to syzygy
so when you have this s mod i you're
coordinating of the orbit closer it will
be a graded module others this is a just
polynomial ring what what is that
and it's dimension of V so this is just
C X 1 X n so then it's a grated module
it will have what's called this minimal
fee resolution so basically well
there'll be a sequence of three modules
and actual finite by Herbert syzygy
theorem so f I is a free module S module
so really s to some power better I and
this are just so you can think if you
choose the basis in those free modules
you can choose you know you can think of
this you have D 1 D 1 D 2 2 D s so this
are really some matrices and well so you
see the point is you will always have 1
generator because it's just a factor of
drink s by some idea so for example f1
will tell you about the equations ok the
module f1 will tell you exactly what are
the defining equation so let's another
thing maybe I'll talk about let me talk
about defining equations you want not
only set theoretic equations but also
defining equations and this will be the
first step resolution I still didn't
define for you plane McCauley so a
typical example just to give you a very
small example the this period is
illusion just to see what or what it is
let's take the 2 by 3 matrix so your
representation actually be some home
from 1 C square 2 C cube
and let's take AI to be the ideal
generated by 3 2 by 2 miners of that
matrix
the know the Hilbert knew that this
resolution will be like this you have s
mode I well it's a cyclic as module so
let's just you know generally goes to 1
this is an S module generate by 1 and
here of course you will have s cubed
because we have three generators Delta
one two maybe let's write minus Delta 1
3 Delta 2 3 and then you if you think
about it you will find some linear
relations namely if you write the
transpose of this matrix
you will see by Laplace expansions of
the matrix with repeated row is that the
composition is zero and it's not
difficult to prove that this is
everything alright so this is a an
example of the minimal resolution which
is slightly non-trivial because that's
not something that you would guess you
know like in one minute maybe it would
take two hours talking about anyway so
that's what we are we are talking about
here so it's always graded so I would
sometimes write this so that's you know
the goal will be a kind of ultimate goal
will be can we find those those even
resolutions of the orbit closures
alright so that's that kind of what okay
McCauley I did not define current
Macaulay has to do with length of this
resolution so X is kind Macaulay
if and only if if the length of this
resolution is just a code I mention of
the zero set of AI and that's also very
useful when you deal the reason really
one of the reasons is it's useful
because you see sometimes if you have
the candidates for the equations of the
variety if you notice it's kinda
Macaulay it allows you to actually
conclude that you really got all the
defining equations okay so that's useful
for equations
wait for example yes and then there's
you know kind of stronger notice
so-called rational singularities I will
not if you have the candidate equation
what do you think you take the
resolution of the candidate equations
and then you see - that's the same
correct points
is there a method sometimes to prove
that something is going to call it
without defining equation so if you know
for some other reasons that s is kind of
Macaulay then if you know that your
equations are good on the open set then
you will know that they are good
everywhere that's kind of you know
generically reduce versus hurt you so
that's really somehow immediate profit
you can have from the kind Macaulay and
then rational singularity is a stronger
property but let me not go there it's
kind of Coahoma logical formulation so
let's a wish list all right
many mother solves this right for the
minimum resolution so I assume it
reduces minimum so you know I will not
have like ones in those matrices you
know I could have stupid generator one
minus one right or something like that
so you allow only in this graded
situation all entries of matrices will
be polynomials of homogeneous pronounce
of positive degree of positive degree so
that's what you that's your that's your
wish list all right so let me now talk a
little bit about which representations
we get which represent the irreducible
presentations of productive groups which
refined to have fine as many orbits
maybe I have to maybe assume that the
group is semi simple
no I didn't that's right it's a good
comment for example it implies that it's
con McCoy
they actually was that's right you can
also say that filbert cheese and
actually in some cases you can even
claim that it's a polynomial even okay
if you're if everything is just in
degree one I mean yeah okay you can you
can set right Hilbert Sirius which
usually if you take dimension of this si
D of the disk homogeneous component it
will become polynomial only for Big D
well it's something that has not
singularities there will be no horse it
will be polynomial right away so that
says very useful because you know the
degree of the polynomial
all right so what's the list I'm
interested in list o VG GB wisp is
another orbits
and the list is interesting by itself
because it's also related to maybe
something about we'll be talking about
tomorrow whoever so I'll give you a list
of some representations groups and
representations and the claim will be
that they are basically like almost all
representational salesman orbits so this
was done by Katzenberg classified Ben
Burke and I guess 1980s right long time
ago already so here it is well first of
all let me just recall about dinking
diagrams so we know that simply algebra
simple
the algebras are classified by root
systems was all by linking diagrams
so there are you know a and B and
therefore serious C and D n is 6 7 8 a 4
and G 2 so maybe a and but maybe you
know I don't want to write the list
everybody can look it up if you don't
know it
anyway so the correspondingly algebras
here will be the classical ones SLN sir
s o n odd s P n so n even for example
and then for those words are quite
exotic so our representations will be
harmonized by a Dilton diagram with a
black doctor okay like a dot and then
I'll tell you how to associate so data
in diagram
is it like a dot but I mean something
like this okay this is black this is
white okay's on why the board is okay
right on blackboard it works the
opposite way but yes okay so let's say
basically okay I really distinguish a
simpler route okay so this corresponds
to I have made Li algebra first point
use the bigger root system this
correspond to sentence degrading I will
not elaborate on that from its finite
dimensional so it goes like this but let
me just give you an example of this
degrading exactly the example
corresponding to this okay and then you
will get the idea
so clearly the big algebra here I have
six dots so it's SL 7 alright but if I
would forget the black dot I get two
disjoint Union so this will be SL 3 and
this would be SL 4 right so you see what
you do you write your GL SL 7 in the
block form 3 3 times 3 3 4 4 and here
you get well kind of SL 3 and SL 4 but
actually you get one more dimensional
space because there's like something in
diagonal matrices but here you get
something you know that I call g1 and
here I called G minus 1 this would be G
0 plus C so you should get it basically
clearly the commutator will respect the
grading so I get that G equals G minus 1
plus G 0 which will be actual SL 3 cross
SL 4 cross C plus G 1 and this G 1 will
be really home from C 4 so I reverse the
block probably I don't know C 4 2 C 3 so
maybe it's C 4 star tensor C 3 anyway so
get those gratings are more complicated
for more complicated algebra so it
doesn't matter and our representation we
are
dress it in okay I didn't tell you I
have this datum my representation V will
be always g1 the first graded component
so in this case will be just home from
c4 to c3
so 4 times 3 matrices all right and of
course this is the group then well of
Xillia algebra but then the group will
act by rows and column operation so this
is very simple example the simplest I
should tell you what the group is so the
group G will be well the group G 0 which
corresponds to the smaller root system
which ok well it has to take adjoint
group because you have to here choices
as to which group do you take and then
there is one copy of C star which
corresponds to this kind of diagonal
elements that we left out okay so
there's a group and then Wenberg theorem
is that invert CRM here
so you're taking the baby and the
unipotent will put intra and the lower
is that right leg lock mm-hmm more than
g1 you will have no just take G 1 G 1
you want you believe what G 1 but there
in general there are other G 2 and
channels yes oh yeah in general it can
go that's right but your representation
is d 1 you take the group G acting on G
1 and the serum is that GV has phantom
in the orbits
and actually cats then classified
representatives find them in orbits
there are only very few irreducible
other representations finitely many
orbits ok yes right Katherine's and cut
it out of those a correction that's
exactly yeah the so cats cats cats cats
doc these are almost all and almost
means they're really very few exceptions
so one can just they make a very small
list yeah yeah it's just like probably
one serious and one example I think or
something like that yeah so it's just
really accidental that there are some
others that have finitely many orbits ok
so so that's quite nice so he black that
will do we will do that right and let me
just show you also how this is a city
with this yes I will give you several
concrete examples so because of course
now if you take some complicated Lee
algebra that you know you don't know
what it is like algebra of type II six
right how do you figure out g1 but it's
very easy to figure out g1
well I mean they don't come from Quivers
it's kind of an analog on just
representative you know for irreducible
positions of algebraic groups of kind of
this trichotomy which is not true like
on the nose but something quite similar
is true because you can always this a
so-called will back representation of
type 1 if you take extended link in
quiver and take a black dot you can also
define G 1 and this will behave very
nicely like the rink of advance would be
a polynomial behave like an adjoint
representation for for the group G okay
so there's this again kind of trichotomy
but it doesn't work on the nose because
there are other representations you know
do some representations for which rink
of advances polynomial ring and here the
list is quite extensive this was
obtained by a little man
so by but you know but at least for this
Lincoln quivers the black dot and
extended into the black dot they exhibit
very similar behavior to finite type and
Tim Quivers okay yeah so let me give you
examples because G 1 is very easy to
figure out ok it's like it seems what do
you do with these six but the point is
like this let's think about just a n
diagram for a moment so if you think
about representation theory then I have
sl5 say here then sometimes you know the
most important are so-called fundamental
representations okay fundamental
representations
of SLN so you know this is SL of some e
which is you see n actually in our
example is c5 so sometimes you think
about this Denton diagram as you know
each node will correspond to one of the
fundamental representation is not
natural labeling so you see for sl5 you
would have here which one is this or XTO
powers who have which to e weight 3e
weights for e alright so let's have you
think about those fundamental
representation so it turns out that if
you it's very easy to figure out G 1 and
let me give you some examples
so you see suppose I gives an example
like that
all right then basically you think of
this is being back I'm corresponding to
the representation so here you've got
the SL 7 okay and here you see the black
dot touches the third one so this is
wedge three c7 and the group is dr7
because you have to pull back the Taurus
okay now if you have the situation like
this let's take the middle dot like the
odd for example then well it touches
three things this is the smaller root
system is you know SL 3 plus SL 3 across
SL - all right well curve C if you take
me out to bra but now what's the
representation it touches here touches
the second so it will be C 3 star and
sar C 3 tensor C - ok and there's a
group you'll have to take product of it
as three and one copy of C star alright
so you can see actually from this you
know you can see this is this nice
exercise well everybody knows for
example that if you have wedge 2e right
there's always find them in orbit skew
symmetric matrices
after all braces well you had only rank
well this is just you see
the end diagram okay but if you look at
the which 3 e where e is CN and you ask
when does it have final minute orbits it
turns out that you can go only up to e8
and then for an hour you know if you
dimension is 9 it does not and actually
that's what they serum says actually
it's so has find them in orbit
no you have this Torah so actually it
will be gln because remember you always
have to put back one copy of see stars
of two SLN you put back copy of the star
you can take gln okay
Lucien so it's fine I mean orbits only
for ends mark was an eight well has to
be careful with triple tensor products
because if you take C two times C three
times CN which does not give this are
exactly the exceptions okay so this has
a bigger thing but because basically
well anyway it doesn't matter but this
one and one series of exceptions so you
see so now if you have your
representation you can actually test
whether you are have a chance or not you
just draw this diagram oh yeah of course
you know you have for example if you
take it he aids they try to you you have
you know like this and you get diagram
of type D and so it will be on of the
spinner repair have spinor
representations okay yeah because you
can put black dot anywhere you want all
right all right
so these are representations so let me
just tell you briefly what is known at
what methods are used I will not go into
the details but so this is well there
are many people working on this so as I
said the cat's Wenberg so first of all
classification of orbits
of orbits also done by bin Berk and he
kind of gives two statements okay one he
just said that basically we have this G
equals summation GI the easy description
but not easy to work with practice you
just take a take a nipple and orbit mg
intersect with G 1
and take your reducible components
right so this is you get all the orbits
just coming back to our example let me
just do the example G 1 G minus 1 and G
0 our SL 7 now you see clearly if you
take the matrix of the type 0 0 0 X well
you get the the matrix that actually
then x squared is 0
so basically well I mean you get only
this oratory that's right so first I
mean what are the orbits in home c43 the
orbits we allow a row and column
operation so these are just ranked
varieties
maybe something given a rank give you a
variety but now suppose now I take a new
pot and orbit which are near pot again
by partitions of seven right and you
look which of them is in G one then you
get an impotent matrix of this type in
SL seven so this will be only orbits
with x squared equals zero so then a
simple combinatorics shows well you can
have some sort on blocks of size two and
this will give you the rank so that's
how it works this is a nipple at orbit
intersected with this G 1 will give you
a matrix of a given rank and this thing
you get all the and this will give you
that's right that's right if you take
yeah but you have to take components and
you know sometimes the important orbits
intersect very badly there are several
orbits of different dimension and so on
everything else can go wrong and then
well it's a 7 by 7 matrix yeah that's
right because you now you are looking at
Newport at orbit in SL 7
well it's matrixes that x squared is 0
yeah so so not x squared equals 0 but
actually 0 0 0 elevators
no but as they are now computer
algorithm actually I should point out
there's no listing from just
classification workers mmm no no because
as I said in orbit can intersect with
many many components of things can go
funny then then he gave the second
classification which is kind of
sophisticated maybe I go in the
direction
second classification
sophisticated
it's the those orbits correspond to some
great subalgebra which are reductive
with certain properties but this then
it's really combined at Oriel so you can
actually work it out and and actually I
should point out it for incidence of
orbits and for for orbit lists is there
our algorithm by V lambda the graph
sorry
there's a begin a computer program on
the line I was slow in taking notes now
I don't understand second a
classification is so potent worth it
take an opponent orbiting G in big lie
algebra intersect with d1 o and then
take irreducible components in this way
you will get all the orbits and there's
a simple tangent space argument okay
anyway all right
question is that this is a finalist
people probably know everything about
these which finite least BNC and the N
is not a finite about that's right let
me tell you because I I want to focus on
actually sixty seventy eight because
because for classical things you get
kind of things similar to two
determinants of varieties so you know
you have some other run condition so
that kind of you can describe by linear
algebra but those 60 78 are are kind of
exotic like this which three c63 c 7 or
3 c 8 alright so yes and what basically
happens it's kind of disappointing from
the point of view of orbit closures so
basically let me just say that every
orbit closer okay what can you say can
you suggest a few words about the second
classification god no because it will
take a series of lectures yeah yeah yeah
no it's sophisticated I mean but yeah
but well one can do it even by hand with
very few mistakes let's put it this way
if you like work on it for one summer or
two summers you know but but but villain
the graph is the algorithm that gives
you even the incidence between the
orbits okay so this is like all anyway
and there are many orbits by the way for
e8 you can get like 62 orbits for
example this is the worst case so there
is some work to do okay right unless you
want to calculate all three resolutions
right but yeah that's maybe too
ambitious but anyway and so every every
orbit
odor is a subspace variety or let me say
has the singular ization by a vector
bundle
okay so I well I have probably 15
minutes so maybe I will just give you
one example let's take the X are inside
of X which is from CMC n does the
example of determinants of varieties
matrices of rank smaller equals and are
then what you can do you can be singular
eyes it you can find varieties E which
will be inside of x times with the
grassmannian
of subspaces of dimension R in C n so
these are picked up under there so your
on G vector bundle on some G mod P
it's for the smaller group already so
basically yeah the usual you know the
camp non stability every every orbit
closure is a stratum you could say or
okay projecting I find a fine everything
is a fine so for example in this project
I meant a variety of this classical
think you can take the pairs of maps Phi
and the subspace are inside of the CN
such that image of Phi this container
are alright and this you know since the
dimension of our is are clearly you
project you the image would be XR and
it's very easy to show that the singular
ization and so on and for those for
those special the representations of
this VIN back data type back type one
everywhere which one is the subspace
variety so then you have this kind of
mumbo-jumbo this go home illogical thing
and
basically what you can do you can do
this box for L file for technique by
wave that's right it's an unexpected
yeah right yeah all right
and basically what you can do you can
give the upper bound on free resolution
here and you can give the lower bound on
no all modules even basically you see it
comes down to calculating cohomology
groups of gmod p on the vs. our gmod P
over which this desynchronization lives
on some X your powers of some
homogeneous vector bundles okay so you
can take a lower bound by taking euler
characteristic and you can take can take
the upper bound by changing this to
associated graded because it becomes
technical exercise complicated so you
can you have something in between
alright and but what does it give well
for rational singularities you need a
lot of vanishing but what was about it
in fact one can get it so what happens
and this is by the way the work of crash
cabbage i guess myself that in those
cases you always can claim that every or
x at least the normalization
Oh X there's a rational singularities
okay so higher direct images vanish
although the coordinating might be not
normal and it is quite often so dizzy
for every for every of those Lindbergh
theta yeah yeah that's right
like this same thing happens for an
airport and Orbitz for example culture
so it's not really unexpected so it's
you know you expect singularities to be
mild all right and for normalization
yeah so we see is the orbiter is not
normal but somehow if you take a little
bigger ring normalization it behaves
nice for each orbit closer normalization
you have this factor okay and now you
see it turns out but you are still if
you want defining equations this is not
enough even for normal orbits because
those bundles I are complicated and your
calculation of exact homology group is
really beyond the reach but you can use
the following trick which was done by
Federico balletto
let's say for normal orbit closures but
for non normally also one can it gets a
little bit complicated so what you do
okay use I'm talking now is sixty
seventy eight okay so you can use
computers and you can try to use my
colleague to the wonderful algebra
system but of course to calculate any of
those resolutions that's way too babe
okay way too big so what you can do and
actually it succeeded in maybe one half
of the cases let's say is the following
from the lower bound you can get the
expected complex can get expected
complex
in all those cases that's right can get
the expected complex but of course you
don't know you get G modules and
expected maps but you don't know whether
there are no ghosts in the resolutions
it could be the same irreducible
carrying and neighboring places it's a
pair since their resolution but it
cancels out but in those cases what
happened who else
so again McCauley to for my colleague to
was too busy but to to to to difficult
but you can do the following interactive
proof which I thought was interesting so
first of all you identify an easy matrix
so some matrix of low degrees that you
can actually write down and just
expected complex somewhere in the middle
sometimes the easiest that you can okay
so we can write down and then start
calculating you know so it will be some
fi2 fi minus one now matrix X and then
start cutting calculating sis ages of X
and X transpose
only calculating first syzygy up to the
expected degree where you expect the
complex to go okay then the calculation
is small and actually in the cases well
he succeeded for you know II 6a 42 and
some cases of e7 so in this way you can
get get matrices to do that for every I
that's right you have to go first is
Utley going this way to the end and that
way to the end to the transpose it's
kind Macaulay so you know it doesn't
matter anyway you can get matrices of
expected resolution some of these oh
yeah you will see example hopefully in a
second if I have time anyway you get
matrix of expected resolution and then
what you do fortunately we have this
fine item in orbit we can use finally
this properties they say you know kind
of classic theorem of books from Eisen
but the exactness criterion of the free
resolution okay so let me just formulate
it because it's useful exactness
criterion
Obama Eisen but
so suppose you have like s to be
actually in an Assyrian ring and you
have a free complex
so you to 0 FN FN minus 1 F 1 F 0 D 1
the N so you think of this complex is
being the set of matrices over this ring
or some text formats and then it just
tells you when this is a cyclic so f is
a cyclic if and only if two things
happen first well think about vector
spaces so when a complex of vector
spaces would be a cyclic finite
dimensional vector spaces of course you
would have to it's a complex so if you
take a vector space is the rank of this
map plus rank of this map has to be
equal to the rank of the vector space in
the middle then you will have exactly
the that is exact so a rank of the I
plus rank of the I plus 1 is equal to t2
equal to rank of F I wait for every I so
this kind of the obvious thing and then
well there has to be something with the
ring all right so we have to do some
ideas so if you have this rank the I is
the rank R I so you look at the idea I
of the I which are our I bar our I
minors of this di so you need to know
that code I mention of this I of the I
is bigger or equal than I for every I so
those ideals have to have you know this
the place where the rank drops here has
to be collimation big oracles and one
bigger goes into bigger cousin 3 etc so
you see now what what you see with I of
the
you know the rank of this map it's RI so
you do have the matrix of rank RI
you take all our I cross RI minors of
that matrix
yeah and so all those ideas of - the
combination has to go up so if you have
ever have an explicitly given complex
that's a way to test ok that it's a
cyclic so you see now what guy later -
he said all those horrible matrices
which you don't even see because the
entries are complicated so you just
store them in the memory but now we also
very very end by definition so now you
have also the representatives of the
orbits okay so just evaluate them on
represent oppose orbits you know Co
dimension of the orbits now you apply
books horizon but you can prove that all
those complex is expected complex are
really cyclic and that basically does
the job okay so this is done for well
yes you require the eyes but if the
orbit is normal as I said it's kind
Macaulay so you can go both ways
actually
all those minor all those places where
drop Frank are the same it doesn't yeah
it is it for general complex but in our
special situation since they think is
kind of a call it means they do what
complex also is basically anyway so this
key did 46 at 4-4 G 2 and some cases 47
so actually this case 47 the most
beautiful that she did oops
okay it's so here's this so we here's a
picture of which three C seven with the
group GL seven acting so you're three
tensors in seven variables right skew
symmetric tensor on seven variables so
you know there are not too many orbit
that's why I picked this is just nine
orbits so I wrote there D bench in the
representatives so you know what happens
actually is it actually only maybe the
most interesting car
those two orbits maybe this one and that
one because
you see those orbits here you can see
that orbits below well let me go I still
have some time you know you can see
these are just a source of rank one
these are you know tensors of rank two
but but is a divisible by a leaner and
so these are general tensor that is
divided by the linear tensor so you can
give kind of the interpretation to all
of those right this is the second secant
of the highest weight vector this is a
certain secant of the orbit of highest
weight vector this is a hypersurface
because there's only one one kind of
small interesting fact is that there's
one in point of degree seven here Delta
invariant SL invariant of degree seven
and there's a good way to see it is to
actually you can see it's cube if you
take a linear maps obviously now wrap
from a wedge five c7 1002 which to c7
this will be twenty one by twenty matrix
of linear form this gives you nose U and
V and this give you the determinant is
Delta cubed or whatever this worse so
these are representatives these are
orbits that right that's right so the
basis is one two three up to seven and
one two three that's right you wanna to
III these are representatives of all
possible orbits so this is a general
orbit this is the open orbit okay this
gives you the generations that's right
sorry I was too quick yeah in a hurry
and then so this is or also wrote the
dimension of each orbit no a closure of
the orbit is union of so that's right
only only the bottom one is that's right
yes
any of those to the cross Mannion just
yes that's right
this this one is a : over the grass
Mannion cone over cone over saw the
other ones are there some higher like
with the sequence this is the first
second
this is a first secant Sigma 2 of grass
Mannion this is I believe Sigma 3 or
grass Mannion so you know you could talk
about rank of the skew symmetric tensor
right in the same way and how many
decomposable you can you know write it
dimensions dimensions of the orbit cover
right hand side on the paranthas EJ
wedgie hey this is 1 2 3 s you one way
to eat wedgie through
that's just what tensor it is
representative of the orbit okay yeah
how you see the desert see comes at the
biggest orbit with 3 I know it's you
know you are lucky I could have written
jealous with 62 orbits you see then what
was happening anyway so that's what it
is and you know so these two have quite
nice resolutions let me just give you
maybe one of them just to and that's
what this galette Oh confirmed I mean
who is writing down matrices and
everything let's see this is a singular
lockers right or seven is a singular
locus of that one this or six I don't
remember I have I think but but I don't
remember right now I don't remember by
heart yeah but that's an interesting
good sorry because you actually you know
your paper with Andre you study the
singular you know I have interpretation
of equations of the opposite of the oh
six okay so I'll yeah so here's the
equations of zero six four which three
see six you have the determinant of
degree 4 so if take all polarizations
also the the you have infantile degree 4
if you take all polarization this gives
you reduced equations of this oh six
but let me just do Oh seven since I'm
out of time just let me just show you
you get quite nice for those orbits of
local dimension you get quite nice
resolutions and there are still some of
them that you would like to do
especially for the c8 so you see so you
basically get this I don't know so or
seven you'll get lengths for so it's a
singular locus of Harvick of
hypersurface right Delta equals zero so
you'll get the following thing I will
write true factors now s65 to the 6d is
by c7 tensor a tensor s minus twelve do
it like this
I've squared four to the fifth II tensor
s minus 10 s for three to the fifth to
the object representation tensor s minus
seven s 3 to the 4 cubed eat and saw s
minus 6 and here you have s in this case
also I should say that look adding has
some work on you basically
I think for the equations he could I
think at least write down guess the
right equations and write down that they
actually vanish on the orbit closer so
you see here what you have actually the
matrix you start with to do this galleta
saying you start with this matrix
because it's linear so you see this is
advant representation this is really up
to determinant some third or fourth xeo
power so such a linear map can be
written down okay it's not too big so
then you do this you know going up and
down and of course what you see here
again it's which three in degrees six
these are just partial derivatives of
the invariant okay but not so easy to
write down that you know I mean the
entries are horrible and then by doing
this going both ways with city G's you
know you get such such nice nice
the resolution okay so that's more or
less everything you know the eight is
still too big definitely too big to
handle even with with computers okay and
it's a pity because especially in the
spinor representation like he ate when
you put the first note that some one
expects some really beautiful goranson
resolutions which are even purer there's
one you reduce it and is a really
magnificent three of them codimension 4
10 and 14 so I would really like somehow
to see once you know that one can write
them down
yes from this resolution or any of the
examples can you read off the dissimilar
information that would work to use the
there is a kind of uniform way of
reading of the singular one the singular
ization for each orbit closer gasps for
the resolution can you think of back and
say here's the back first of all is the
choice of vector Bank is not unique
sometimes you have like many you know
five or six of them I mean yeah it's
just completely somehow yeah the data is
kind of I would love to analyze you know
how they vary from one to another but
they're just too much data it was
horrible files you know and the use you
have like you know hundreds of complexes
whatever you know yeah so but but
definitely for some orbit clauses is
unique the singular ization for some
there are more than one and they are not
obviously related by any symmetry that
one can kind of see right away okay so
there are always other DC like this at
the farm that's right exactly yeah this
is just by SL to triple you know you do
SL to propellant it's really goes back
to craft processes like for yeah and you
take bigger it wasn't too late I should
point out even though the orbits are
easy our positions are easy to work out
you know the symmetric algebra with 57
to get horrible multiplicities because
the only thing that happens is this one
invariant so there are no inverse L
invariant but the other weights you can
oh yeah
well also there are formulas you know
the same Coahoma logical formulas if
this vanishing Euler characteristic will
give you the composition of s mod I okay
of you know components graded components
of s mod I but you know I mean okay so
you get you know in a given degree you
can calculate but but somehow I don't
know if there's any meaning
belly-up you get any driven ever need
anything I don't know I mean mmm
hard to say at this moment a big picture
that there's some smaller examples that
are still open for it that you could
calculate the equations or versus G's
that you don't know but sort of smaller
after somebody to do well I I think they
one of the interesting cases I think is
see three times over to see five if I
remember correctly which seems manage
jobs are not so many orbits and there's
actually one very interesting you know
when the orbit is not normal then you
can play what I call the Cochran l game
okay you get the module which is
normalization model is a ring and they
think supporting on smaller orbit and
then you try to see it as kind of a
twisted version of this you know and see
whether you can do so there's one very
interesting orbit there or because it
was just not normal and we cannot figure
out how to play the corner game this
actually would be like the first example
of to look at and this is a seven so
it's not too big you know it's not just
this Co Colonel it's not just directly
one module support another smaller orbit
and I think like this analysis would
give you know some kind of deeper
understanding or as to what happens in
general so this example I think is
significant somehow for more general you
know you know I can I can show
I think they orbit maybe not today but I
can send you away may other
there's a particular already yeah
witchcraft cave is actually is a Hilbert
series of normalization we calculated
for sixty seventy eight and then clearly
from Stanley theorem you can see the
symmetry properties of the hilbert space
and gives you gornstein garner right
away especially in this in some it
depends it varies in a wild way for ei
for example some if you take C for as I
was to see five which is kind of the
biggest one which sixty two orbits you
get very few normal orbits it's kind of
disappointing but in this spinner V
Omega seventy-seven right I mean then in
this we have I think maybe even every
orbit is goranson or something like that
but most of them are gornstein and and
and there's a really beautiful you know
expected resolution so nice that it just
must mean something so it's yeah so
that's somehow